astronomers have now unveiled the first
image of a supermassive black hole
located right at the center of our very
own milky way galaxy this groundbreaking
image
is the product of an international team
of scientists known as the event horizon
telescope collaboration
the cosmic body is named sagittarius a
star
the black hole was estimated to have 4
million times the mass of our sun it's
located about 26 000
light years from earth
scientists say the discovery will help
improve our understanding of what
happens at the center of our galaxy
dr sarah iso is the nasa einstein fellow
at the harvard and smithsonian center
for astrophysics she's part of the team
that captured the image of this black
hole and i asked her to explain more
about what exactly we are seeing here
right so the black hole itself we don't
see but what we see is the shadow it
casts on
on all the swirling gas that goes around
it
so the black hole itself has all these
gas swirling around it that it eats up
or ejects out and this gas because it's
rotating uh very rapidly around the
black hole it's very very hot and it
radiates and it radiates radio waves
that we observe with the eht and so
these radio waves create this glow that
we see around the black hole and this
black hole is actually inside this dark
patch which we call the shadow that it
casts onto this uh swirling hot gas
it's fascinating especially just to
think that radio waves were taking those
to make an
image
do we know
what is inside the black hole will we
ever be able to actually look inside
with
you know the technology that we have
right no we don't know uh what is inside
a black hole and actually going to see
what is beyond the event horizon is
impossible uh
the the um
the description of the event horizon is
really the point of no return so even if
you go in there and see what it is you
wouldn't be able to
come back out and tell anyone
so what would happen to us i mean this
is for you know all of the fellow space
nerds out there i mean what would happen
if we were to actually try to peer
inside and go in
right um so this depends on which black
hole you choose to go into
if you go to a
solar mass black so very small black
holes uh the ones that are about the
mass of our sun uh there if you get too
close to the black hole you get
spaghettified you get stretched out into
thin spaghetti uh before falling into
the black hole but for supermassive
black holes like sagittarius a star or
or famous first image of a blackhole the
blackline m87 they're so big so large
and so massive that you would just kind
of float right in and nothing would
happen to you you'd just enjoy the view
i
yeah i guess so if you if you could make
it the 26 what is it 26 000 light years
away that you would have to travel right
yeah fascinating yes it's a pretty long
way it's it's a long way and what does
this mean though for research now i mean
i know it's an exciting time to actually
be able to to put an image to something
that you know we hear about um what will
this mean though for moving further for
research
right um so the black hole at the center
of our galaxy has uh had indirect
evidence that it was there for a while
and in 2020 the nobel prize in physics
was partly awarded to studies of orbits
of stars in our galactic center that
have very peculiar orbits around this a
very dark and hidden compact mass and we
have thought a lot about what this mass
could be and the best scenario is that
it's a black hole but that's always been
indirect evidence that it is a black
hole and today we're actually seeing it
for the first time so today is really
the first time we have direct evidence
that at the center of our galaxy there
is a black hole which is i think is
pretty amazing
not only that we have now two black
holes that we can see
and these two black holes are fairly
different in size and
their environment they are in very
different galaxies both m87 and
sagittarius star behave very differently
and now we have two black holes we can
study and i think it's really opening up
a new laboratory for black hole
astrophysics and that's really exciting
it's fascinating and um
dr sarah eisenhower we appreciate you
sharing your enthusiasm and helping us
layman also to understand
what's inside the black hole thank you
thank you